we shocked when we heard of the horrific
events that unfolded in Nottingham and
as a church we were in heart one with
the mood of the nation in grieving and
mourning for the loss of the victims and
our hearts went out to the families and
when I saw the photographs of the
victims in the in the press it just it
was overwhelming to think that lives
have just been cut down like that so
horrifically and so our hearts went out
to the victims and we were praying for
them and for their families and now of
course we've been shocked and
overwhelmed to understand that there is
a connection
with a family in the church and that's
been quite overwhelming actually because
they're a good family